Academy award-winning Fiona Aldridge
takes this year's nominated costume
designs and shows us how they might
become the close of tomorrow
our first nominee Enrico sabatini for
the mission our Fashions are in jewel
tones for late evening Pirates designed
by Anthony Powell pataloons and tight
apocalypse
Devon and John bright for a room with a
view the Timeless Romance of lemon
Theodora van rental for Peggy Sue got
married the 1950s polka dots petticoats
go on Dancing
Anna Annie and Mauricio milanaki for
Othello and the grand finale to every
fashion show the winners are Jenny Bevin
and John bright for a room with a view
[Applause]